your surgeon will perform a
skin grafting procedure to repair
severely damaged or missing skin by transplanting
healthy skin to the area where the damaged skin is located
the skin has three main layers the
epidermis
the dermis
and the hypodermis or subcutaneous layer which
contains fat blood vessels  and
nerves
the skin is the largest organ in the
body it performs many
main functions including physically covering the
body protecting the inside
of the body
and regulating body temperature
and providing the sense of touch
in some cases your skin can become
so damaged that it will not heal properly it is
Your doctor may recommend a
skin graft procedure to
treat many skin conditions
including a non-healing wound a
severe burn a skin ulcer a
skin biopsy a large surgical wound
or a skin infection before
your procedure you may  receive
general or local anesthesia
if the surgeon uses his pro  pia
healthy skin called an autograft
he or she may create a partial skin graft
or a full-thickness skin graft
depending on the depth
of skin the graft must cover
after cleaning the area of healthy skin calle
the donor site  surgeon will
use an instrument called a
hematoma to remove very thin layers
of skin creating a partial skin
graft for full thickness skin grafts
the surgeon will use a scalpel to
remove all layers of skin from
the donor site
once your surgeons determine the
type  of skin graft you need he
or she will clean the damaged area of skin and remov
any dead or disea
ed tissue your surgeon will place the skin
raft over the wound and hold it in pl
ce with stitches then the surgeon will
pply an ointment to the graft and
cover it with gauze
finally the surgeon may
use bandages to secure the graft
and apply pressure while the graft is
sticks to the surrounding skin after
the procedure your
doctor may give you
intravenous or oral pain medication and
may need to increase the
amount of calories and protein in your
diet to help your skin heal
for the first few days afterward  to the
procedure you will need to protect
the skin graft site you will need to keep the
donor site dry while it heals you
should also avoid strenuous activities
until your doctor says it is okay
and you may need to
visit your doctor several times to
have the wound and skin cleaned  cover with a
bandage as your wound heals